special edition of pftpm getting you
ready for the 2020 draft and one of the
guys who will be participating in the
nfl draft from home like everybody else
except the folks who are going to be at
espn studios in bristol connecticut it's
rayquan davis alabama defensive tackle
rayquan how are you pal
i'm good i'm doing good how you doing
i'm doing great and you know we're all
dealing with this upside down crazy
world and i think back to the scouting
combine and we saw you there in the room
where we were broadcasting we were
hoping to talk to you there the world
has dramatically changed right when you
were on the brink of pro day workouts
private workouts visits to team
facilities
how did you personally deal with
everything that you thought your life
was going to be over the next two months
completely changing
um right now it's it's out of everybody
control it's just
you know just still just trying to just
stay healthy and um
you know just stay stand up and stay
home
just out the way
were you planning to spend most of your
time at a training facility like in
florida or somewhere else and then you
just had to come back to mississippi how
did that play out for you
yes sir um i was in cali training for
the combine um
after the combine i was still i was
gonna go back to cali and uh continue
training and um and they told us we all
had to we had we had to lead cali so i
just came back to mississippi
what do you do now to stay in shape when
you're back home and you know different
guys have different stuff at home that
they can work with things they can do
and also you got to find the motivation
when you're at home which is always hard
for me to do how have you managed to
stay in shape during this i'm just doing
cardio you know and um
i just go to my coaches house he got
like a gym in his basement and i do some
things there but i just do a lot just a
lot of cardio a lot of court work
and um
nice little place in my coaching house
that's it
one of the big changes in this whole
process is talking to teams like this
through facetime and i saw part of your
interview with the cowboys with jerry
jones and stephen jones and you gave
them all a good laugh when you mentioned
that the one guy you bring with you from
alabama was nick saban i thought that
was great uh from your perspective
how how weird is it to be talking into
your phone to guys like stephen jones
and jerry jones who have been such a key
part of the league for so many years
um
i mean it was crazy i mean i just
it was just great just to get that
experience just to talk to them just
just to be there on the facetime with
them but um
yeah we definitely had a little funny
moment and um
it was funny because everyone they asked
me who i bring i told him coach save and
i
thought it was funny
yeah jerry said you can't bring him we
got a coach did now they didn't
yeah i i didn't see how it went from
there did they ever push you on which
player you would bring
uh yeah that was that was the question
there was um they wanted they wanted to
know what player
what player i would i would take you
know to the nfl with me i couldn't
answer because like i would want to take
the whole team so i had to
i had to answer the question so i just i
told nick haven
so you were able to get them off of it
all together they never came back around
and asked you for the name of a player
no
no
they did
all right so i'm asking you now give me
the name of one guy that you would bring
with you
um
[Music]
one guy
uh
uh
i bring say it
cedric
why is
[Laughter]
he's great he's great at what you do and
you know
he motivated us on the sideline so i
bring him
let me ask this from a player's
perspective who's the biggest badass
that you ever played with who was a
member of the alabama program during the
entire time you were there the one guy
you just don't want to mess with
nick saban
i believe that
they say that he's funny
what about him but what have you seen
that made you conclude that he's funny
at times
oh just the things you do like when we
practice
i can't i can't say on here but it just
just know they're funny
you can say they [ __ ]
no no no no
[Laughter]
we're not going to send it we're not
going to send it to any teams
um you just be like
it just be like you know
bring it today or
get your a with all day
but
he is so intense though i interviewed
him years ago and he's very calm up
above the table but under the table his
legs going about you know a thousand
miles an hour
and he's always got that kind of
intensity his personality and i'm sure
at some point you got on the wrong side
of nick's safe and i think everybody
does at some point is there a time that
stands out for you that you got him
really upset uh and uh what was it if if
that happened that caused him to get
upset
um
he don't like he don't like talking like
talking to the um
other side of the ball like the offense
so uh one day
um like i was doing like a lot of
talking to like our office talking trash
and he just can't kick you out of
practice until you get out
wow he'll kick you out yeah
was that the only time did you learn
your lesson after just one experience
like that
uh yeah that was everybody
hey one thing i do before these
interviews i take a look at the twitter
page and i noticed you have a pinned
tweet that's over three years old i'm
gonna do everything they said i wouldn't
do and i mean it's been there since
november 23 2016. so it seems like
that's something that still motivates
you today what what causes you to to say
that what caused you to make that kind
of like your your bedrock principle that
that everyone sees when they visit your
twitter page
oh just i just got a lot of people but
like i got a lot of people to prove
wrong
i got a lot of people that um back then
it was down me to even like graduate get
through college
uh
now we're talking about nfl with me so
it's it's crazy
but i just put it right there just to
just keep me motivated to keep my mind
on it
you know
but yeah that's why i was up there
though
who is it that you wanted to prove wrong
the most
oh everybody i mean just everybody that
had like a bad thought about me and just
any type of way is that for them so you
can see it but why why do you think they
felt that way what was going on i mean
it's three and a half years ago you've
grown a lot since then but what was
happening that was causing people to
have the wrong idea and doubt you
um i don't know it's just
i mean people have their own i mean
opinion about you you know just
and
i don't know it's just you know it's
just something i wanted to stand out
right there and
something i want to look at just to keep
me motivated
so you you've had the ability to talk to
as many teams as want to talk to you one
of the rules that they've put in place
since they can't bring guys in every
team can talk to every prospect they can
talk to them up to three times a week
for an hour at a time who have you heard
from the most over the past month or so
oh man it's
it's been a lot of teams
um
a lot of teams like 49ers uh
packers uh miami miami dolphin
uh
ravens
the eagles
there's been so many teams
but who have you heard
would you say since they can since they
can call you three times a week is there
a team that you've been hearing from
over and over and over again not just
hey let's have a quick conversation but
let's talk you know on a regular basis
between now and the draft any teams that
have been in regular contact with you
oh yeah like names the ones i just named
yeah
so it's been more than just one phone
call hi hello how are you it's been
regular contact with those teams
yes sir
who were you who were you a fan of
growing up both player and team who's
the player you looked up to and who's
the team that you're rooted for
um i didn't watch that much like
football growing up but when i got to uh
alabama
like my favorite person to watch with
alvin thompson
who's that now
david thompson
i see that you wear number 99
what what brought you to wear number 99
what inspired you to do that
oh it's just been my football number
since high school
was there i mean is it just the number
is it the number they gave you or did
you want to wear a number 99 because of
warren sapp or anyone else
no i just i wanted i just wanted that
um
when did you know
in your own heart that you had what it
takes to make it to the nfl what what
was there a moment on the practice field
a moment in a game just one day you woke
up and you just felt different what was
it that made you believe you can do it
oh because i just had a high motor i
just love working
and um
i just i love football so
when i put all that together and when
you got the passion for it just
you know it's all there right there so
what's the best thing what's the best
thing rayquan davis does on a football
field the number one best thing
stop to run
and and what's your what's your approach
to stopping the run what do you do is it
all i mean do you have a plan for it is
it instinctive when you know that that
ball is going to be handed off to a
running back what is it that you do that
allows you to to excel at that task
um i just read my keys just look at my
formations look at the guy i'm all
and just i just realized stuff around me
i just go on my face i just go off that
right there
give me something that you know you're
gonna have to improve at to be as good
as you can be in the nfl
um
i mean i i do a pretty good job clapping
the pocket it just uh
it's like being being double teamed my
past person you know
trying to get around guys
does it frustrate you when you get
double teamed or do you know that you're
helping the team even though you're not
going to get the sack because they're
doing everything they can to keep you
away from the quarterback but one of
your other guys is more likely to get it
do you get any relief in that does it
make you feel good at all if someone
else gets the sack or does it piss you
off that you're not the one who's
getting to the quarterback
no i just i just look at it as like uh
i'm helping the team because i know if
i'm getting double i know somebody's
free
and um i just look at some like i'm
doing
i'm helping you know it don't matter
all right so draft night's coming up
next thursday you're going to be one of
the guys who's participating from home
what's your plan where where are you
going to be and who's going to be with
you
i'll be a couple of my family members i
know i'm going to be in alabama
now do you uh
are you gonna are you gonna are you
gonna put on the suit like you put on
for the draft itself you got you got the
clothes picked out as if you were gonna
be there to see the commissioner in
person or you're just gonna be casual
this casual
you got all the equipment they're
sending cameras out they're gonna have
everything set up i mean it sounds like
it's gonna get complicated do you have
everything you need to to basically plug
into the nfl and and have the camera on
throughout the draft until your name's
picked yeah yeah i'm gonna set my camera
up and stuff
yeah i do
do you have a sense of what your your
ceiling and your floor may be for the
draft i mean most guys have that that
idea of when that that range is going to
be when they can expect their name to be
called do you have a sense high and low
when you can expect to get a phone call
no i don't right now
i don't know
um
who's the guy that you've seen during
your time playing football uh that you
may not want to see again at the nfl
level is there a guy out there that just
really stood out to you as a guy that
you know you just had a hard time
getting passed or there was a level of
physicality there that you just to soon
deal with other players instead of him
is there just one name out there that's
lurking in the nfl that you saw when you
were playing in the sec
no
are you the guy that they're not going
to want to mess with is that why
yeah probably so
one of your teammates tua tagovailoa has
been the subject of a lot of
conversation about his future if i was
an nfl team and i was asking you what
does tua bring to the table and should i
put my quarterback position in his hands
what would you say
uh i'm like yeah he's a um he's a leader
you know i've lost the team
through
situations
he just uh he's just a leader
well hey rayquan i wish you all the best
moving forward i congratulate you on
proving all the people wrong who were
doubting you back in november of 2016.
and i i look forward to seeing what you
do at the nfl level good luck moving
forward congratulations on everything
you've done and i hope to talk to you
once we know what team you're on
all right thank you
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports